[Musik]
das besondere dieses tages ist aus
meiner sicht dass die faz natürlich
ihren siebzigsten geburtstag feiert
wofür wofür wir als deutsche börse der
faz alles gute wünschen für die nächsten
70 jahre
[Musik]
wahrscheinlichkeit dass die tatsächlich
bedeuten dürften ist 90
ja aber für eine institution wie die faz
ist es eine besondere ehrung und das
wird nur wenigen zugestandenen der
frankfurter allgemeinen zeitung im namen
der geschäftsführung und meine
herausgeber kollegen danke ich ihnen
sehr herzlich dafür dass sie heute mit
uns sozusagen in unseren geburtstag
hinein zu stücken meine damen und herren
freiheit beginnt mit f und früchte aus
finnland hat sie heute hier
[Musik]
[Applaus]